6 43 here on a wednesday morning it is
wednesday and that means it's time for
our morning cup of joe segment metro
police sheriff joe lombardo joining us
live this morning
to talk about things happening across
the valley sheriff good to see you once
again sir
good morning john i have to apologize
first and foremost i
dressed down a little bit i had shoulder
surgery so i'm on light duty right now
well uh for well good luck with the
recovery and we'll send the angry
letters your direction
let's start let's start with the case
actually though from uh from last week a
pretty serious situation that took place
we covered it here officers shot and
killed a burglary suspect in the spanish
hills neighborhood
uh the suspect is obviously deceased now
but what if detectives learned about
this case kind of what
led to it and any possible connection
between the
suspect and the homeowner
first and foremost we haven't determined
any connection between the suspect and
the homeowner
unfortunately you know this case
happened uh it was a pretty dire
situation
um and fortunately we responded in a
timely manner and
um i believe if our intervention had not
occurred
um there could have been serious harm to
either the wife or the husband in this
situation
and if you saw the video uh post ois
officer involved shooting the um it was
a pretty dire situation
with the uh individual it appeared to me
personally that
he was in the throes of going to kill
the guy with a hammer so
um but to explain the situation uh
there was access to this high-end
neighborhood it's up on
in the southwest part of town
the citizen had alerted
in-house security to the
you know the suspect being in the area
and security attempted to locate him was
unable to locate him and eventually we
were called to the scene by the
homeowner
because he had access to the residence
so
what was his intent high-end burglary
it's a high-end neighborhood
probably some good stuff to to steal uh
fortunately they had some device you
know security devices burglar alarm and
all that to
to assist them in preventing this type
of crime and but the fact that it
happened it happened
um so people have to be aware no matter
where you live yeah you know sometimes
there's a sense of
security false sense of security when
you live in a high-end neighborhood and
you have your own security and you have
your own alarm systems
you still have to be aware of your
environment and still do everything you
can to prevent that from happening
that's a good point the sheriff there's
a lot of communities around the valley
so it's something people have to know
you were saying
i i just wanted to clarify to the
community that it's not a rash
of this type of crime we're actually
down 30 percent
property crimes across the valley uh
valley wide
so i don't want people to panic well
sheriff let's talk about something that
is uh
increasing and metro police is seeing a
lot of thefts of catalytic converters
so why are these being taken out of
people's cars
god i wish i knew you know you know i
was just talking to my folks
why is this happening again i i can't
remember how many years ago this was a
thing
because of the problems we had with the
salvage yards and fencing
uh locations auto garages and that they
were accepting them as a form of
payment or you know a form of barter or
you know it was just a financial gain to
the suspects
and then all of a sudden this uh started
to occur again
um unfortunately we've had over 145
thefts in the last four months but we
did have
um an arrest of four individuals here
recently
now my question was has the catalytic
converter thefts
uh ceased since the arrest and the
answer is no uh
they're continuing to happen so what we
need is people to be aware
if there's people crawling under the car
in the middle of the day
you know because this is happening in
shopping parking lots the most common
areas apartment complex
parking lots um people need to be
questioned if it doesn't seem right it
probably isn't right
and it's probably appropriate for you to
call us so we can respond
and deal with it and to date we have not
identified
offense associated with this crime
interesting
i'm sorry to cut you off john that's not
something that's unique to the las vegas
valley on this one
either seattle just reported out a
significant number of
catalytic converter thefts in their
jurisdiction here so
i'm sure it's occurring all over let's
switch gears a little bit no pun
intended to
new year's eve we've talked about this a
little bit before
it's right around the corner what are
the preparations from metro police
we know things are going to be different
is it going to be different from a law
enforcement standpoint
no the majority of it will be the same
as you know we start preparing for new
year's eve
months and months and months of early
prior to the event
because it takes a lot of time and
resources to bring to bear to the event
but you're right it's going to be
different this year there's no fireworks
associated with new year's eve along the
strip corridor
i believe the plaza hotel intends to do
some form or fashion of fireworks
and within their area in the downtown
area
downtown specifically is still working
on a permit
to have the ability to do a pay-to-play
type event down in the fremont street
area but we have the social distancing
issues associated with that so i don't
know what the status of that is
as we speak today um but we should have
an answer this week on that
but reference to las vegas strip we're
going to
have the same footprint we normally have
i just looked at the numbers we're going
to have 100 approximately 100 less
officers this year as compared to last
year
but the couple of the big changes is
the road shutdowns east and west and
north and south
that will occur occur at reno boulevard
and spring mountain this year
usually it goes all the way to sahara
yeah change that format
and then uh um the complete closure of
las vegas boulevard will occur a couple
hours later so
right around 8pm versus 6pm this year so
a couple changes but we've got to be
prepared fair enough sheriff lamardo
thank you again for joining us this
morning if you have a question for the
sheriff
you can submit it at eight newsnow dot
com and find out if it's answered every
wednesday